[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 3 mai
une bonne nouvelle pour l'emploi la
poste lance une campagne de recrutement
145 cdi sont à pourvoir avec ou sans
expérience des embauches qui
s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'un accord
signé il ya quelques semaines avec les
syndicats du travail il en cherche aussi
les plus jeunes pour financer leurs
études ou partir en vacances un forum
spécial était organisée cet après-midi
attrapa rendez vous annuel élargi cette
année à l'apprentissage les détails à
suivre dans ce journal est enfin
d'édition vous découvrirez le football
club phénix de versailles une toute
nouvelle équipe créée en février sa
particularité elle est constituée
uniquement de réfugiés nous les avons
suivis lors d'un entraînement
c'est la fin d'une pause qui aura duré
plus de six mois pour la société car
matt basé à vélizy villacoublay et
conceptrice du projet de coeur
artificiel est autorisé de nouveau à
reprendre ces essais cliniques la
nouvelle a été confirmée hier par l'
agence nationale du médicament les
recherches étaient stoppés depuis
octobre et la mort du dernier patients
implantés
lagence nationale du médicament a
notamment indiqué que la société avait
apporté les éléments nécessaires pour
une reprise de ces essais dans les
conditions de sécurité et de maîtrise
satisfaisante car ma prévoit d'ailleurs
l'ouverture du nouveau site de
production d'ici la fin de l'année 2010
est là je vous le disais dans les titres
la poste qui compte plus de 2000 facteur
dans les yvelines lance une nouvelle
campagne de recrutement une centaine de
cdi sur une base de 35 heures sont
proposés pour des candidats avec ou sans
diplôme c'est deux fois plus que l'an
passé objectif accompagner la
transformation des secteurs de
l'entreprise les détails avec haussmann
vendeurs d michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude la poste
recrute dans les yvelines la direction
vient d'annoncer l'embauché de 145
facteur 10 6
en 2010 est le double de l'année
dernière cette décision fait suite à un
accord national signé fin février
ce document prévoit 3000 postiers
supplémentaires sur le territoire
français nous notre objectif c'est
effectivement de recruter de recruter
des personnels qui eux vont nous
permettre de renforcer notre notre force
de travail donc ça ça reste important
mais c'est pas pour aller plus vite
c'est au contraire pour avoir des
personnes qui soient plus polyvalente
plus qualifiés mais qu'ils puissent
aussi s'adapter à nos métiers depuis le
début de l'année 45 candidats ont déjà
été recrutées en cdd sur le département
les facteurs sont payées sur la base du
smic pour entendre de travail de 35
heures
leurs journées commencent tous les jours
entre 7h et 8h c'est plutôt dans des
établissements une partie de tri de
préparation du courrier dans le sens de
la tournée avec différents produits tels
que le courrier ou le colis et puis
aller à distribuer tous les produits
autre objectif de ces recrutements
répondre à la vive raison 2.0 mise en
place par la poste les nouveaux facteurs
seront formés pendant quinze jours à
leur arrivée pour maîtriser les nouveaux
outils digitaux
au début je croyais que c'était
difficile j'ai eu du mal mais je me suis
je me suis fait je pense que tout le
monde peut s'y faire et moi je suis pas
tout jeune donc je pense que les plus
jeunes peuvent s'y faire sur le mois
d'avril la poste recherche
principalement des postiers sur saint
quentin en yvelines versailles
rambouillet et croissy-sur-seine aucun
diplôme spécifique n'est demandé il faut
simplement être titulaire d'un permis b
voiture on reste à trappes ou un forum
jobs d'été de l'apprentissage était
organisée cet après midi au gymnase jean
guimier une première sous ce format pour
la ville mise en place depuis deux mois
par la mairie l événement a attiré plus
d'une quarantaine d'entreprises et 500
jeunes curieux armés de leur cv et de
leur lettre de motivation
retour sur ce rendez vous avec michael
et demi d'euros et et stéphane servant
chaïma benedit 18 ans n'a pas hésité à
pousser les portes du gymnase guimier
pour participer au premier grand forum
job d'été de l'apprentissage de trappes
sous cette formule
l'objectif de cette lycéenne en
terminale es trouver un emploi pour la
période estivale
on est venu dans mon lycée on nous a on
nous a distribué en fait des petites
feuilles
du coup je suis parti me renseigner à la
cyberbase et voilà on m'a dit on m'a dit
le concept et je trouve vraiment le
concept assez intéressant de ramener
différence entreprise ça que je me suis
déplacé shy'm avez la possibilité de
rencontrer une quarantaine d'entreprises
des professionnels qui ont travaillé
pendant plus de deux mois avec la mairie
pour participer à cet événement en fait
le but pour nous ça va être de trouver
notamment des stagiaires des alternants
cdd cdi qui pourrait correspondre donc à
nos offres les compétences ne m'importe
m'importe peu ce que je cherchais des
personnalités après plus d'une heure de
recherches et une quinzaine de cv
distribué l'étudiant de 18 ans dresse un
premier bilan
c'est un salon cas c'est intéressant
parce que voilà j'ai fait plusieurs
plusieurs stands qui sont assez
différents on nous parle de l'entreprise
de ce qu'ils font particulièrement de ce
qu'ils proposent
l'événement a attiré plus de 500 jeunes
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
rendez vous devrait être renouvelée
l'année prochaine
c'est un nom qui ne vous dira sûrement
rien du tout le football club de phoenix
est une nouvelle équipe créée il ya
quelques semaines composé uniquement de
réfugiés
le fcp s'entraînent chaque samedi matin
sur un terrain à versailles l'initiative
est portée par des bénévoles avec l'idée
de créer du lien entre les réfugiés et
les footballeurs locaux reportage
stéphane servant et nicolas landry
soudanais somaliens ou afghans hébergés
à versailles ou dans les environs se
retrouve désormais chaque semaine pour
une séance d'entraînement de football
ils sont une vingtaine à s'adonner à ce
sport universel à l'initiative d'une
association de bénévoles voisins
solidaires 78 ce collectif de bénévoles
accompagnent déjà les réfugiés il
participe avec la croix-rouge à des
distributions de nourriture à des
sorties et un suivi administratif
ils ont alors senti une forte demande de
faire du sport ensemble du football en
particulier
c'est simplement pour pouvoir proposer
une activité à nos amis réfugiés parce
que ils sont ils ont pas la possibilité
de travailler
donc il faut les divertir leur trouver
des occupations et on pensait que le
foot était une des occupations possible
l'occasion de créer des liens entre les
joueurs de différentes communautés et
des habitants curieux et souvent
bienveillant des joueurs amateurs très
heureux de jouer ensemble
je suis très heureux de jouer ici avec
les autres réfugiés de différents pays
et une gifle en crise prochaine étape
des matchs avec des équipes de foot
local une rencontre est déjà prévu en
mai et d'autres se préparent en région
parisienne grâce à la page facebook du
football club phénix un moyen de
développer de nouveaux contacts de
trouver des bénévoles et de lancer une
cagnotte pour acheter des équipements
pour les joueurs et si vous souhaitez
soutenir cette initiative sachez que
l'équipe recherche des fonds notamment
encore des chaussures de foot vous
pouvez faire un don en vous rendant sur
la page facebook du pénis phoenix
football-club de versailles on poursuit
toujours avec du sport et du foot mais
du futsal
une pratique qui recense plus de 135
club dans les yvelines il y a quelques
jours les finales départementales
étaient organisées à fontenay le fleury
14 équipes dont les seniors féminines de
montigny le bretonneux se sont affrontés
pour espérer soulever la coupe
retour sur cette compétition avec
michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
d'andré le futsal était à l'honneur à
fontenelle flux
ries la ville accueilli ce dimanche 30
avril au gymnase les cartes les finales
de la coupe les yvelines
au programme sept matches de la
catégorie des moins de 12 ans aux
seniors
comme souvent dans le futsal les
rencontres ont été ultra spectaculaire
avec notamment un 17-1 entre le psg le
fc mantois dans la catégorie 8 16
féminines on peut perdre 3 0 et à
l'arrivée gagné 5-3 c'est plutôt une
attaque défense quoi
c'est à dire que les joueurs arrière on
pour envoyer les ballons devant et c'est
les attaquants puisque les avoir pour
marquer dans la catégorie senior
féminine les joueuses de l'ice
montigny-le-bretonneux habitué à joie on
sur un grand terrain se sont lancés dans
l'aventuré futsal cette saison après
avoir réussi à se hisser au final lésiné
montaigne qui jouent en blanc se sont
finalement inclinés contre
croissy-sur-seine sur le score de 4 buts
à 1 je pense qu'on est entre guillemets
on fait des cadeaux en première mi-temps
et puis on joue pas le on joue pas le
match à fond fait quelques erreurs
tactiques par rapport à ce qu'avait dit
le coach on est au début du match
et bah c'est ce qui nous coûte les deux
premiers buts après c'est compliqué à
une fois qu'on se prend un but dès le
début de la deuxième mi-temps après 2
pour revenir c'est vrai que elle va elle
sert bien le jeu et c'est compliqué de
marquer on a pas mal d'occasions on
cadre pas aussi toutes les eaux casque
on a donc à montigny le bretonneux
tentera de monter une nouvelle équipe
l'année prochaine pour remporter la
coupe en attendant les joueuses vont
tenter d'arracher noté en dh en fin de
saison et cette fois ci sur la pelouse
dans le reste de l'actualité sportive
les excellents résultats du club
guyancourt orientation 78 au championnat
de france de course d'orientation le
club local a remporté deux titres de
vice champion national un résultat
positif et qui confirme la place du club
parmi les meilleurs du pays et coûté à
ce propos l'une de ses membres au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude c'est de
la course à pied on peut le faire en
marchant mais pour gagner vaut mieux
courir et
aussi on a tout un apprentissage de la
technique c'est à dire la lecture de
cartes pour savoir où on doit aller
savoir se repérer par rapport au terrain
faire le rapport entre la carte et le
terrain pour trouver les balises que
l'on doit pointer tout au long du
circuit jusqu'à l'arrivée
comme en athlétisme on va voir du 100 m
200 m 1000 m voilà eh ben on a sprinté
moyennes distances longues distances et
on a aussi des courses de relais
on referme cette page sportive avec la
course j'en assume qui se tenait ce
week-end en vallée de chevreuse parmi
plusieurs milliers de cyclotouristes ont
pu emprunter en famille ou seul les
centaines de kilomètres de chemins
boisés de la vallée pour cette 25e
édition reportage de nicolas landry et
stéphane servant
c'était l'évènement pour tous les
passionnés de vélo et de cyclotourisme
la 25e édition de la jean racine se
tenait dans la vallée de chevreuse le
week end du 29 et du 30 avril plus de
trois mille cyclistes de toute l'île de
france s'étaient donné rendez vous pour
des parcours à vélo en forêt ou sur
route
l'occasion de se retrouver en famille ou
entre amis tu n'est aujourd'hui pas
parce que on a l'habitude de sortir la
tête avec les amis puis c'est l'occasion
de tous se retrouver de se rassembler
dans la région alors combien de
différents coins de la france les
parcours vtt de 17 à 120 kilomètres mais
également un salon avec des stands des
ateliers des exposants sous le signe
cette année de l'éco mobilité sur salon
on trouve beaucoup d'exposants beaucoup
de marques beaucoup de magasins aussi du
coin de la région d'avesnes chevreuse on
trouve aussi de l'andi loisir puisque
nous
on souhaite faire la promotion de l'éco
mobilité donc des vélos danser dans ses
grandes lignes
que ce soit pour les gens valides que
pour les gens valides s'est pas
uniquement le vélo sportif ceci le vélo
loisirs donc le vélo parler au travail
le vélo pour aller à la piscine le vélo
aussi pour le travail solidarité aussi
avec un stand roulons solidaire où toute
la famille pouvait participer au profit
de l'institut pasteur 5 km ça fait 1
euros pour l'association
donc je veux bien faire beaucoup de
kilomètres c'était aussi la possibilité
pour tous les jeunes de pratiquer en
toute sécurité et 2 et des figures
renversante
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
on a retrouvé en replay et sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]